hello everyone tickets are on sale for marvel
studios thor love and thunder that's right we're
back and we've got so much to show you like goats
and corgs well one cork kids get to popcorn now
new worlds need yours new asgard new goats
seriously why the goat obsession no reason
Welcome back everyone this is a brand new thor
love and thunder trailer video there's a bunch of
new footage and easter eggs so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's a bunch
of really big stuff coming up and we're doing
some really cool giveaways too i'll start with
the brand new footage then i'll talk about thor
versus thanos the celestials and some of the other
really powerful cosmic characters that you see
show up in the trailers when you talk about the
most powerful characters in the mcu the multiverse
because now we've seen the multiverse and doctor
strange too they're actual gods which we do see
during this movie of many different power levels
they're cosmic beings like the celestials and
then you have cosmic entities which are basically
ideas given physical form all of them have vastly
different power levels and they just keep getting
more and more powerful like you're talking about
the most op stuff you've ever seen in the mcu
the celestials in the eternals movie was just
the beginning of this during the gorr storyline
in the comics thor briefly gains enough power to
become the god of gods basically inside the mcu
so during the trailer you see footage of thor
trying to rally a new team of revengers it's a
bit of a call back to thor ragnarok is only a
couple of characters because as everybody you see
go to olympus korg valkyrie and jane foster's thor
character the guardians of the galaxy have already
kind of gone their separate way by that point in
the movie i love the idea though that he takes
the tour boat like he takes the boat that they're
using for tours he takes the goats with him and
he takes mjolnir to use the rainbow bridge on the
boat instead of just taking them with the rainbow
bridge the funny thing is he doesn't actually need
the goats he doesn't need the ship either he can
open the bifrost directly with storm breaker so
he doesn't need to do that you notice the boat
is called the age ear here on the side that's
just the norse personification of the actual sea
they have the funny joke about taika bringing the
actual goat into the promo that they did for the
movie like buy tickets and don't mind this goat
that's just walking around here on this set he
uses them to travel around the universe when he
becomes unworthy during the mighty thor storyline
but because that's not an issue during this movie
it's just more of a funny thing like okay we're
going to use the boat we'll use the goats we'll
use stormbreaker to take it the slow way the
funny scene of thor trying to play hype man
to the new revengers team that he's putting
together to go fight gorr is just inside one
of the main halls at new asgard the joke here
is that valkyrie is just getting really bored
with the idea of being king like she thought that
it would be cool but it's just a lot of paperwork
also trying to earn money and help her people
which is where all the tourism stuff comes in
which she's not super happy about either so the
whole idea is that she loves the idea of going
on this adventure with thor to go fight this giant
battle against someone who's threatening to kill
all the gods in the universe she also misses the
valkyrie like she's really sad because all of
her sisters died when they were fighting hela and
it's been a long time since she's been with them
so when jane foster gets mjolnir and becomes a
version of thor she gets really excited about that
and thinks of her as a sister of hers so it is
always possible that jane foster could help reform
the valkyrie under king valkyrie at new asgard
they are doing the cancer subplot so mjolnir does
kill her just a little bit every time she uses its
power but that's because it burns all the chemo
out of her body so the cancer just comes back and
starts killing her faster every time she becomes
thor and like i talk about thor becoming god of
gods briefly during the storyline even though
she becomes worthy enough to wield mjolnir and it
reforms and that gives her the power of thor that
doesn't also make her like a super powerful god
of gods level character it just gives her the same
level of power that thor had when odin made that
enchantment which was kind of like a middle level
version of thor the ways the gods become more
powerful though is by gaining more followers and
they can go through other cosmic trials gain other
cosmic artifacts game big power-ups themselves
gorr is one of those characters too where he
basically goes around killing all the gods
trying to attain more power basically taking the
power of different gods it sounds like that's kind
of the way the necro sword is working in the
movie like it's leeching the life force out of
different gods because this actually looks like a
version of the god bomb this giant black and white
nebula planet-looking area here where you see them
fighting one of the distinctions now that you can
see because of some extra footage is when thor
is swinging stormbreaker at the necro sword he's
black and white everything around them is black
and white but you see color pouring off of thor
in his armor so they're trying to show you the
power of the gods in a visual kind of way in the
way the necrosaurus seems like it's absorbing that
when he's reading off his new team he mentions the
guardians of the galaxy they have that funny scene
with groot and rocket the way they cut that in the
trailer is a little misleading it's happening
during a completely different part of the movie
that's all during the early part of the film when
thor is having his existential crisis before he
goes back to new asgard with valkyrie but i do
love the scene where korg forgets what her name is
and calls her jody foster jody foster also legit
famous he would be familiar with some of earth's
culture at this point then there's actually a huge
easter egg where gorr says you're not like the
other gods that i fought before when he actually
fights thor for the first time he's already been
killing gods for a long time he's already mowed
through a bunch of them there was going to be a
big reference to that during moon night but as
when he encounters thor that he comes up with
the idea to go back in time and take the power
of all these other gods and basically winds up
becoming a god himself so to speak because when
he fights thor for the first time it's the first
time that he's ever had trouble killing a god thor
is able to hold his own against him and it really
surprises him because the movie is only going
to be about two hours long obviously they're not
going to do the entire gorr storyline from the
comics so they'll probably only be some easter
eggs for the god bomb storyline which is basically
the end of the gorr storyline and even though we
just had the loki series with kang in a bunch of
time travel we just had doctor strange 2 with a
bunch of multiverse with different versions
of characters during the gorr storyline in
the comics there are multiple versions of thor
from different parts of the timeline you have
a young thor you have middle age thor and then
you have old king thor i think they've replaced
the multiple thor storyline with the mighty thor
storyline so you still have two versions of thor
but it's just present-day thor with jane foster's
thor we might still get that scene where he does
wield two hammers so to speak now it would be
stormbreaker and mjolnir so technically it's not
two hammers it's an axe and a hammer it would be a
cool callback to avengers end game because he was
about to do that before captain america showed up
and he started wielding mjolnir but in the comics
the big deal with him wielding two hammers is that
the hammers themselves contain sentient cosmic
storms so basically he's wielding more power than
anyone's ever had in the entire mcu at that point
that brief moment gives him so much of a power
up that he smashes both hammers together and it
winds up destroying all of gorr's plans with his
god bomb it basically destroys the entire thing
and winds up absorbing the necro sword so wielding
the power of two hammers and the power of the
necro sword makes him god of gods inside the mcu
very briefly the big easter egg i think for that
where thor basically becomes the most powerful
he's ever been for a brief period is when he's
here with jane foster's story their clutching
hands and he's talking about why he's more
powerful because he's fighting for something that
he loves they'll tie him becoming a more cosmic
version of the character like god of gods briefly
back around to the title love and thunder that's
kind of the way these giant hollywood movies work
too is that usually the big twist of the movie in
the end like the way they defeat the villain has
something to do with the theme of the actual title
the big connection between gorr and thanos is
that they both have giant universe spanning
plans and they both have a similar arc they both
feel like they were wrong by their people gorr i
think is a little more sympathetic though thanos
goes around balancing the universe one planet at
a time eventually trying to save the universe
albeit doing it in a really wtf kind of way
eventually he gets his big power up the infinity
stones and tries to do it in one fell swoop
gorr basically goes through the exact same type of
arc now he's wrong by the gods so he wants to kill
them all because he feels like they're terrible
and he's not wrong you've seen konchu in the
moon night series he is terrible but he started
out doing things the same way that thanos did
going around one pantheon at a time killing all
the gods eventually he tries to work smarter not
harder and develops a way to do it all at once his
infinity stone version of the plan that is the god
bomb what's going on here looks like his grand
plan to basically wipe out all gods across the
entire cosmos all in one fell swoop so for those
of you asking who's more powerful gorr or thanos
eventually gorr would become more powerful but
that's following the gorr storyline in the comics
and he winds up going back to kill an elder god
and steal his power at the beginning of time
basically giving him as much power as you
could possibly ever get so when we talk
about elder gods that's like cathode the
god of chaos the person who gave scarlet
witch all of her chaos magic there was an
easter egg for him during doctor strange too
so they've started to canonize the elder
gods inside the mcu in a much bigger way
maybe we'll see them in some of the crazier
supernatural based movies in the future
when they bring scarlet witch back
eventually and they will bring her back
mark my words she is not dead if they did a
scarlet witch solo movie then they would probably
do cathone in a movie like that tycho what td did
say there would be a bunch of cameos in the movie
so lay all your bets in the comments below about
who's going to show up speaking of sony though
they just released a brand new first look at
spider-man across the spider-verse i'll try to
finish my easter eggs and breakdown video for it
before the end of the day but if i don't finish
it then i'll post it early tomorrow morning will
you wait for everything everyone click here for
my marvel thunderbolts announcement video and
click here for my miss marvel episode 1 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!